now breaking news coming out of Spain
where the uh Football Association there
has sacked the women's Coach jori vilda
uh for more on this breaking news we can
talk to our presenter Andy uh Richardson
I mean this is a saga that has spiraled
out of control and the the Spanish coach
wasn't the one that committed the kiss
so why has he been fired yeah he's a big
Ally of a bit of context for for
everyone this comes off the back of leis
rubial as the Federation president
president um kissing Jenny hos so the
world cut win on the lips without her
consent after their World Cup win an
action which is completely overshadowed
the the team's success on the pitch hge
vilda the the coach of the women's team
a big Ally and friend and staunch
supporter of Ruby ales when uh the
Football Federation held um an
extraordinary uh general meeting at
which it was thought rubiales would step
down when in fact he he got up and
defended his position rubiales um was
supported uh by filda at that meeting
yesterday we had the men's team the
Spanish men's team issuing a statement
saying they were apped by what rubianos
had done and how it had taken away from
the success of the women's team so the
pressure was growing and vilda has now
um lost his job as part of the The Wider
reforms that uh the Federation
Presidents had promised to bring in
there was a meeting of of the the
Spanish Federation in the wake of all
this and it was very telling that of the
the 140 members meeting only six were
women and this was one of the things
they promised was going to change and
really it seemed that his position was
untenable also bearing in mind there'
been so many complaints about vilda from
the players in the buildup to the World
Cup um 12 of of of Spain's leading
players didn't make it to the tournament
um because they'd fallen out with the
coach they said the training conditions
were unacceptable the the atmosphere
around the squad wasn't right the
Federation at that point backed filder
12 leading players did not go to the
World Cup because of discontent with the
coach and with everything that's
happened subsequently and the fact that
we we see now that it wasn't just an
isolated incident or moments of Madness
on the pitch there was systemic problems
within the Football Federation vilder
really had to go despite bringing the
World Cup to his country this obviously
now perhaps puts more pressure on the
investigation around Luis rubiales
because obviously FIFA are involved now
um how does this play out because as you
say it's tarnished the whole Victory by
the by the team and has put Spain in the
spotlight for the all the wrong reasons
yeah and I think what it's I think the
reason it's become such a a global story
and not just a a Spanish Football story
is that so many women involved in sports
uh can look at what happened to HOSA
look at what happened under under vilda
with those players and they can relate
to it um there was a a survey done by
women in sports in the UK um which is an
umbrella organization representing lots
of women involved in football and they
said that 80% of women had faced
discrimination in the workplace on the
football pitch but that only around 20%
felt empowered to actually complain
about it or do anything about it so I
think it's it's become a an issue that
has has got Global residance Rubi Al is
officially is still in the job he's a
powerful man at UEFA European uh the
European governing body who's still not
really come out and condemned his
behavior he a vice president there he's
a friend of the the UF president
Alexander cheerin at the moment he's
still in a job but uh FIFA the world
governing body have suspended him from
all football related activity there is
an investigation ongoing there's
investigations ongoing within Spain as
well um so at the moment the Football
Federation is going to allow those
processes to play out before they take
any action against how does this all
then impact Andy really on on The Wider
topic that most probably uh teams across
Europe and their Club chairman are
actually discussing you know the way
that the female players are being
treated within the huge teams like
Bayern Munich and Arsenal and Manchester
United I mean you know there's there's
no Scandal there at the moment but
inevitably chairman team managers
coaches everybody's going to be asked is
everything okay in our house do we have
something to worry about absolutely and
I think that's what that's what's come
out over the over the last um over the
last few few days and weeks since since
this all happened that is not just an
isolated issue this is not just uh Ruby
ales having a a moment of euphoria and
getting carried away on a on a platform
in front of front of the world this was
just emblematic of of far wider issues
we see in Spain there was uh the coach
prior to vilda ignasio Keda um there
were
complaints repeatedly about his behavior
he was but he was left in charge of the
team for more than 20 years despite
players saying he's a bully uh there are
problems the players were ignored and I
think what we have now is a situation
whereby UEFA FIFA individual federations
have to make sure that players are
empowered um they have to have um an
ability to be listened to an ability uh
not to be ignored because it's clear
that in the past their complaints right
up until this world cup have just been
ignored Andy it's obviously a story that
is going to evolve uh throughout the uh
day here on Al of course we'll get more
analysis from you and our teams across
the world really on what's going on
thanks very much